[Musique]
bonsoir le début d'une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 bienvenue
dans ce journal du lundi 5 juillet voici
les titres quatre pôles santé sur un
site de 37 hectares la mutuelle générale
de l'éducation nationale a inauguré son
nouveau site l'institut mgen a été
modernisé à la derrière avec une
capacité désormais de 450 lits pour ce
faire plus de trois ans de travaux ont
été nécessaires pour ce lieu présents
sur place depuis 1959
ce programme a été lancé par le
gouvernement pour revitaliser les
territoires ruraux petite ville de
denain a bénéficié également aux
communes du département et 10 des
yvelines ont été retenues pour profiter
d'un soutien en ingénierie de projets de
financement ciblé
reportage à besné joueurs pour chartrain
et invités florence granger député des
yvelines
et puis direction chatou à la fin de ce
journal la ville accueillera le 18
juillet prochain la dernière étape du
tour de france 2000 2021 en attendant on
fêtait la grande boucle ce week-end au
programme animations pour petits et
grands autour du vélo bien évidemment et
dans cette édition également reportage à
vélizy-villacoublay la majeure partie de
la ville sera bientôt chauffée grâce à
la géothermie
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ses titres
après plusieurs semaines de recul
qu'ovide 19 repart à la hausse dans les
yvelines si vous regardez ces chiffres
collectés sur une semaine elles légère
augmentation du taux d'incidence le
nombre de nouveaux contaminés sur 100000
habitants + 0 4 point et depuis le 1er
juillet le taux de positivité au test
lui est au même niveau qu'il ya une
semaine une tendance similaire à celle
observée au niveau national le ministre
de la santé olivier ferrand a mis en
garde les français ce week-end sur une
possible quatrième vague face à la
menace du variant delta il a appelé
également une vaccination plus massive
est du côté des hôpitaux en revanche la
baisse du nombre de patients se confirme
22 hospitalisations en moins en une
semaine à 22 patients toujours en
réanimation et depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire 1848 personnes sont
décédées du colis 19 dans les hôpitaux
du département
après plus de trois ans de travaux
l'institut mgen située à la verrière
s'est refait une beauté quatre pôles sur
37 hectares de terrain si l'ouverture
des lieux s'est effectuée à la fin de
l'année 2020 l'inauguration des lieux
que la semaine dernière retour avec
mélanie poker c'est un peu le joyau des
équipes soignantes ce bassin de
balnéothérapie n'a pas encore pu
recevant de patients crise est née terre
oblige depuis octobre novembre 2020 les
patients ont intégré le tout nouvel
institut mgen sur les pôles santé
mentale qui ont eux intégrer les locaux
depuis plus d'un an effectivement c'est
les patients ont intégré locaux et c'est
quasiment complet
par contre sur les pas d'un rien une
montée en charge progressive en plus il
ya une augmentation de capacité par
rapport à l'établissement précédent il
est passé à 186 places versus 116 4
pôles santé sur 37 hectares de terrain
des bâtiments à haute qualité
environnementale
l'institut a aujourd'hui une capacité de
450 lits le chantier a permis de
rapprocher les différents services au
travers notamment
de tous les aspects sociaux thérapie
avec le travail qui est fait autour de
la bibliothèque des patients qui est
aussi la vidéothèque des résidents de
l'ehpad avec la prise en charge autour
de l'idée que le patient est un citoyen
le résident est un citoyen et que
aussi bien l'un que l'autre doivent
trouver leur place dans la vie de
l'institut et dans la reconstruction
face à leur maladie
le site a été inauguré le vendredi 2
juillet dernier en présence de nadia et
ministre de la ville installé dans le
parc du château de la vérie hier
l'institut pourrait passer un
partenariat avec la ville le lien entre
la verrière hellemmes jeunes doit être
renforcée donc on a répondu
conjointement à un appel à projet de la
rs l' agence régionale de santé pour
avoir des médecins ville hôpital qui se
partageraient entre une activité pour
les very roi est une activité pour la
mgen donc on attend la réponse de la rs
un centre de santé pourrait aussi voir
le jour pour pallier l'absence de
médecins sur la commune
le chantier de l'institut débuter à
l'été 2016 a représenté un
investissement de 100 millions d'euros
[Musique]
améliorer les conditions de vie des
habitants des petites communes et
territoires alentours c'est le but du
programme petite ville de demain initiée
par l' agence nationale de la cohésion
des territoires plus de 1600 communes
ont été retenues dont 10 dans les
yvelines la semaine dernière ben et
joueurs pour chartrain organisé leur
premier comité de projet et mélanie
poker patrick jacques de dixmude et
juliette prigent elles ont 18 mois de
travail pour créer un projet de
territoire les villes de ben et de
jouars-pontchartrain font partie du
projet petite ville de demain des
problématiques communes comme des
espaces publics à requalifier où le
patrimoine d'autres plus spécifiques à
ben le collège doit être reconstruit
d'ici 2026 pour accueillir 850 élèves
une fois le collège détruit 2
de revitaliser tout ce cas tout ce
quartier où il ya le collège
il ya aussi le gymnase eu aussi pas de
choses on a une gare routière aussi lé
parking tout refaire ce quartier là
peut-être faire une place je ne sais pas
moi c'est une idée qui masse comme ça y
est une place comme dans un village du
côté de jouars-pontchartrain la
problématique est principalement lié à
la circulation
la ville est actuellement traversées par
la d900 12 il ya des problèmes des
changeurs de la nationale 12 cantons en
bas de la commune à l'entrée de ville
ouest
en fait l'état construit un
demi-échangeur terre tout est là pour
que l'échangeur soit en double
circulation mais c'est ça change eur on
ne peut aller que dans le sens vers
dreux c'est à dire tous les gens qui
viennent du bassin sud qui ont besoin de
prendre douze par paris pourrait le
prendre à ce demi échangeur mais n'est
pas ouvert ils sont obligés de traverser
notre commune je vois qu'on cherche là
pour aller prendre plus haut niveau de
sainte apolline le travail se fera aussi
en lien avec les habitants des deux
communes
un chef de projet a été nommé huit
autres villes yvelinois sont concernées
trois milliards d'euros sont estimés par
le gouvernement pour les 1600 communes
retenues et on continue à parler de ce
sujet petite ville de demain avec mon
invité par téléphone florence granger
bonsoir vous êtes la députée la
république en marge de la 12e
circonscription des yvelines 12e
circonscription dont fait partie cette
commune de ben qui a été injustement
retenus dans le cadre de ce programme
elles vivent de demain alors pour rappel
il a été lancé le 1er octobre 2020 par
jacqueline gourault ministre de la
cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales avec un objectif principal
celui de revitaliser les territoires
ruraux pourquoi lancer ce dispositif
pour le gouvernement pourquoi il était
primordial justement d'enclencher cette
dynamique de redynamisation
mais écoutez l'état un programme pour
lequel on a eu déjà des actions qui
avaient été menées sur la redynamisation
des centres villes avec la première le
premier programme qui s'appelait action
coeur de ville qui avait été lancé en
décembre 2007 et pour lequel d'ailleurs
dans la circonscription j'avais poissy
qui étaient concernés et là l'objectif
il est de poursuivre et de renforcer ce
programme est de renforcer
les fonctionnalités des petites villes
pour améliorer le cadre de vie en milieu
rural et conforter le rôle en fête de la
ruralité dans la transition écologique
et l' équilibre territorial avec un
objectif vous en avez parlé améliorer le
cadre de vie des habitants ça pour
l'améliorer il faut redynamiser
peut-être remettre du commerce local
refinancer peut-être des projets pour
redynamiser justement ces territoires
ruraux
oui et puis également permettre à une
partie de la population française qui
vit dans les territoires faut savoir
qu'à 38 pourtant la population 37 bis
dans ces territoires et bien d'avoir
également un meilleur accès par exemple
vous le dites au commerce mais d'avoir
un meilleur accès également au service
public d'avoir un meilleur accès aux
soins d'avoir en fait une qualité de vie
qui soit celle que l'on peut à trouver
dans les grandes dans les grandes villes
il est donc avoir la possibilité en fait
de ne pas sortir de la ruralité pour
avoir accès à certains services
notamment l'objectif c'est de de
retisser le lien de proximité avec les
services publics la population rurale de
redynamiser tous ces territoires ruraux
qui sont habitées et qui n'ont pas
aujourd'hui les mêmes d'accès aux
services d'état que les plus grandes les
plus grandes communes on a l'objectif
est également de de repenser les
mobilités ont donc les mobilités à 12 et
bien évidemment aussi l'objectif de
ramener la culture et les écoles dans
les territoires ruraux
donc le plein de sujets qui sont
concernés par ce programme qui est donc
lancé jusqu'en 2026 un plus de 1600
commune accompagné par ce programme pour
un montant de trois milliards d'euros
jusqu'en 2026 et donc le disait dix
communes dans les yvelines il y à ben
may aussi ablis
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines jouars
pontchartrain à houdan maul epône
rosny-sur-seine bonnières sur seine et
freneuse neuf contrats au total pour dix
communes concernées dans les yvelines
avec à chaque fois ces communes
c'est des communes de moins de vingt
mille habitants florence granger qui
sont concernés et l'idée de ces communes
c'est qu'elle joue une certaine forme
elles ont un rôle de centralité c'est ça
par rapport aux autres communes qui les
entourent dans leur territoire
oui tout à fait c'est tout à fait ça en
fait ce sont des communes qui ont été
sélectionnés l'ont été les sélectionnés
par un comité avec donc les préfets
suite à des dossiers de candidatures qui
ont été remontés et on les a
sélectionnées en fonction des thèmes qui
avaient été remontés par les élus locaux
l'objectif est d'être au plus près au
plus près du terrain avec donc la
commune de ben qui est concernée qui
fait partie de la 12e circonscription
des yvelines pour laquelle vous êtes
député du coup la candidature assez fait
comment est ce que vous avez accompagné
vous personnellement la la commune de
ben est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
accompagner la commune de ben dans
l'établissement justement de ces projets
parce que il ya plusieurs piliers
notamment financement d'ingénierie sur
place le financement aussi de projets
ciblés plusieurs choses qui sont rendues
possibles grâce à ce programme petite
ville de demain alors que ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas le type à moi en tant que
député qui vais accompagner en fait il
ya un chef de projet puisqu'on a mis 250
millions d'euros pour qu'il y ait des
chefs de projet qui puisse accompagner
donc l'ensemble des communes retenues
dans la réalisation enfin le montage en
fait de tout et de tout les projets en
revanche j'ai des relations régulières
avec la commune de ben avec le conseil
municipal et j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
d'échanger sur commande les relais
thématiques sur lesquelles la commune de
ben souhaiteraient travailler la colline
de ben en fait souhaite retravailler sur
deux choses essentielles dans le centre
le centre bourg
et puis également le quartier du val des
quatre pignon donc l'objectif après
d'avoir des échanges avec l'élu au
niveau national mais dans ce programme
dans cette petite ville de demain
l'objectif c'est vraiment de donner la
voix aux petites communes rurales et
l'objectif il
vraiment que on est des projets qu'ils
soient au plus près des préoccupations
des habitants
voilà donc que ça c'est faire la
sélection des dossiers
le député donnait des informations j'ai
pu donner j'étais en contact avec la
ville de ben pour donner un certain
nombre d'informations
en revanche toute la mise en oeuvre
toute la sélection et tout le projet il
a été sous l'égide de madame la
sous-préfète madame geromini donc il ya
eu même réunion d'installation la
semaine dernière de ce comité j étais
invité j'ai pas pu y participer mais
c'était sous la direction de noam la
sous préfète qui a participé à la
sélection des projets qui ont été
retenus avec une dernière chose une
dernière question que je souhaitais vous
posez oui on a compris soutien en
ingéniérie financement sur des mesures
thématiques ciblées
l'idée aussi c'est qu'ils aient une
certaine forme de mise en réseau au sein
d'un club des petites villes de demain
ça peut favoriser justement de nouveaux
projets d de l'innovation aussi au sein
de cette mise en relation
exactement je crois que l'objectif il
est de donner une voix plus importante a
encore à la ruralité qu'on a commencé à
faire donc dès le premier programme
coeur de ville de façon à ce que on
puisse avoir vraiment qu'on appelle le
mieux vivre
en fait dans la dans la ruralité et
emmanuel macron président de la
république a bien rappelé que en fait
l'objectif est d'avoir des projets de
vie de vivre ensemble des projets qu'ils
soient des projets plus humaniste et des
projets de qualité donc de donner
vraiment la fois à la ruralité aux élus
locaux aux habitants à toutes les
personnes qui font concernés merci flon
second jeu d'abord être avec nous je
vais entrer sur nère fille je vous
souhaite une bonne journée merci repart
également et je le rappelle député de la
12e circonscription des yvelines
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également le nouveau
conseil régional d'île de france
installé vendredi sans surprise valérie
pécresse a été réélue présidente de la
région les vice-présidents est également
désigné les nouveaux conseillers
régionaux eux ont pu découvrir la
nouvelle institution l'institution du
conseil régional les détails dans ce
sujet de nicolas landry un nouveau
mandat dans la continuité du précédent
commence au conseil régional d'île de
france valérie pécresse a été réélue
présidente de l'institution régionale
avec un objectif clair pour les
prochaines années une île de france que
je veux rassembler autour d'un grand
dessein celui de faire de notre région
l'une des plus entreprenante et des plus
belles à vivre de france voire même
d'europe lors de cette séance
d'installation 15 vice-présidents ont
été désignés pour la commission
permanente
parmi eux othman nasri avec la
délégation suivante jeunesse promesse
républicaine orientation insertion
professionnelle enseignement supérieur
et recherche
c'est très important pour les emplois de
demain parce que derrière c'est la
formation de la jeunesse
derrière c'est l'attractivité derrière
c'est aussi la relocalisation
industrielle d'un certain nombre
d'activités
l'île de france est aussi la ruralité
nouveau conseiller régional thomas
gourland est aussi président de
rambouillet territoire avec cette
volonté d'agir pour l'intérêt de
l'intercommunalité et de la région notre
présidente valérie pécresse a vraiment
choisi d'avoir une égalité entre lol
l'urbain et le rural
la présidente avait annoncé dans son
programme tout à 20 minutes dans le
rural donc on va travailler énormément
sur ce point là et on va préserver notre
environnement travailler avec les
agriculteurs
du côté de l'opposition l'union de la
gauche a obtenu 53 sièges
un mot d'ordre la défense de
l'environnement et d'une justice sociale
l'enjeu pour nous c'est rappeler
l'urgence d'agir sur le climat et les
solidarités on l'a vu pendant la crise
sanitaire il ya un enjeu d'inégalités de
lutter contre les inégalités de
anticipées
de prévoir la région ile-de-france à
2030 à 2040 pour la génération qui vient
avec respectivement 16 et 15 sièges le
rassemblement national et la république
en marche sont dans une opposition
minoritaire
on nous oppose ans lorsque nous
penserons que les décisions ne sont pas
les bonnes et évidemment en allant dans
le sens des décisions lorsqu'elle nous
paraîtront les bonnes d'être une
opposition
indéterminée sérieuse et pertinente
prochain rendez vous pour les 209
conseillers régionaux une séance prévue
le 21 juillet prochain les travaux de
géothermie continue à
vélizy-villacoublay nouvelle étape la
construction du bâtiment d'exploitation
cette technologie dite du multi brun qui
va permettre de chauffer une bonne
partie de la ville est une grande
première en europe le reportage de
patrick jacques de dixmude et de
juliette prigent
les travaux au bord des routes à
vélizy-villacoublay vont durer encore
quelques mois il s'agit du chantier
d'installation de la géothermie
cette énergie décarbonée va fournir de
l'eau chaude sanitaire et du chauffage
urbain 9000 foyers et 20 % des
entreprises bélizienne une bonne
solution pour la municipalité
si on faisait rien simplement avec
l'augmentation des taxes et si on
trouvait pas de solution pour basculer
sur une nouvelle énergie dans les cinq
ans le prix du chauffage urbain a doublé
donc là il y avait notre volonté de
protéger participer à la protection de
la planète
et puis en plus avec une solution
vertueuse haut niveau à du porte-monnaie
chaque pays la géothermie consiste à
aller recueillir la chaleur enfouis sous
le sol
ici à vélizy la technique de forage est
une première en europe
elle va alimenter le réseau de chaleur
de la ville à 66 % d'énergies
renouvelables notamment grâce à une
avancée technologique
celui ci a une particularité en dehors
d'être effectivement en grand dans sa
taille c'est que il y à une innovation
qui était mis en une initiation que l'on
appelle multi drame c'est à dire qu'au
bout de mon forage g3 drain en fait
qu'ils sont au niveau de ce qu'on
appelle le dogger à 1500 mètres en
dessous de 2
de la surface où nous sommes
actuellement et sedrun là vont aller
capter de la meilleure manière l'énergie
géothermale de manière à pouvoir être
certain de récupérer cette énergie et la
fournir sur le réseau en ce moment c'est
le bâtiment d'exploitation qui est en
cours de construction les travaux
devraient finir en novembre prochain
pour une mise en service dans les foyers
en décembre 2021
avant de refermer ce journal le tour de
france se rapproche des yvelines le 18
juillet prochain l'ultime étape de la
grande boucle s'élancera de chatou et
direction les champs elysées à cette
occasion la ville organisait ce week-end
ça fait du tour l'événement a pris place
sur l'île des impressionnistes
l objectif sensibiliser et développer la
pratique du vélo michael et demi d'euros
et justine brasier al'approche du
passage du tour de france à chatou la
ville a mis le vélo à l'honneur le temps
d'un week end les 3 et 4 juillet l'île
des impressionnistes accueillait la fête
du tour le but promouvoir le département
et le vélo sous toutes ses formes c'est
de rappeler que les yvelines est
vraiment une terre de vélo fin on
accueille d'événements beaucoup
d'événements sportifs nationaux fin
on développe beaucoup de vélo route
aussi sur le sur le territoire donc on a
cet aspect loisirs tourisme sportifs
événementiels sur place plusieurs
activités freestyle airbag vélo smoothie
parcours pour les enfants ou encore cet
atelier sur les drôles de vélo en tandem
inverser un tout petit vélo micro bike
aux plus grands le granby par exemple
s'est effectivement montré qu'il ya
plein de façons différentes de faire du
vélo qu'on a des réflexes à vélo qu'on
oublie qu'on a et quand on utilise un
vélo un peu différent il faut changer sa
façon de faire on arrivé là bas très
longtemps mais on a déjà fait deux trois
activités pour l'instant les enfants
sont super contents donc mes parents
sont contents pour les enfants pour les
grands même pour découvrir des vélos un
petit peu extraordinaire
on a vu là bas sur l'activité avec des
tout petits vélos et des grands vélo on
vient d'arriver on a découvert cet
atelier les plans de vélo un peu bizarre
affaire on l'a fait avec les enfants
j'en ai fait un peu tout seul ça c'est
super sympa le départ de la dernière
étape du tour de france partira de
chatou le dimanche 18 juillet et dans un
instant ne manquez pas le retour de
l'émission c'est fluide sport présentée
par michael et demi d'euros voilà c'est
la fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité
très belle soirée avec td 78
[Musique]